Này Bòn Đi Ba Kha Hai và nhà thuốc Lâm Châu Khi Kết lên mình mình bắt, chúng ta hiểu trống hàng ra, vì một Việt Nam khỏe mạnh.
Vừa qua ngành dược phẩm Việt Nam khi nhận một giấu mất quan trọng khi nhắn hàng lên này Bòn Đi Ba Kha hai cùng vệ thống nhà thuốc Lâm Châu,
và hơn 2 mệt tự nhiệm lưỡn trong vòng ngoài nước chính thức tham gia lên mình mình bắt, một sang kiến tin phòng bị dữ mình bắt toàn diện trong dược phẩm.
Lễ Khi Kết thì hiện các mạnh mẽ của các đơn vị trong việc mình bắt tự nguồn nguyên liệu, quy chính xả sốt, phân phố đến kiểm nghiệm độc lập với sự đông hàng của việc kiểm nghiệm thuốc chú ương, đơn vị kiểm nghiệm dược phẩm đồng nạn thuốc bộ ý tế.
Lên mình mình bạt hướng tới 3 mục tiêu chiến lượng.
Mình bạt quan diện tư đồng vào đến đầu ra sản phẩm.
Chú đồng kiểm nghiệm độc lập với qua chần tốn tủ tối thiệu.
Sẽ dự hệ sinh thái ít tế công bằng, tinh cẩy vào mình bại cho cậu nồng.
Trong buổi cảnh kỹ trường dược phẩm Việt Nam vẫn đăng đối mặt với nạn hàng giả và hàng kém chất lượng, sự kiện này được xem lành động viên phòng đã lựa ít người tư dụng lên hàng đầu.
Không chỉ nói về chất lượng mà chính miếng bằng haynh độc, đại dựa lên miếng mình bạt nhấn mạnh tại lấy kỳ kết.
Tung qua việc cùng nhau cảm kết và haynh độc, các mềm kỳ vọng sẽ có phần năng cao tư trình này, bảo vệ sức khỏe cộng đồng và tự mức hiện thật quá mục tiêu vì một Việt Nam khỏe mạnh hơn.